Hi there, everyone.
I'm Brady, and I make the
Numberphile videos.
And this is a bit of a
supplementary video for our
one about Benford's Law.
Now hopefully you've already
watched that, and you know
what Benford's Law is.
But just a reminder, everything
we're talking about
here pertains to the
first digit of
all these big numbers.
So let's get into it.
What we've done is an analysis
of the statistics of
Numberphile videos to find out
whether or not they're
following Benford's Law.
Now I'd love to say I did
this myself, but it's a
bit beyond my skills.
I was helped by a very clever
man named Daniel, so
thank you to him.
So what I've done is I've given
Daniel the duration of
every Numberphile video in
seconds, the number of times
it's been viewed, and the number
of comments that have
been made on each video.
So what he's done is he's looked
at the first digit of
all those numbers and plotted
them on a graph, finding out
what digit is most commonly at
the start of the number.
And here's the graph.
Now let's look at these
one by one.
First of all, there's
the durations.
And for those of you who
remember what a good Benford
curve looks like, well,
it looks like this.
So we haven't got a
very good match.
Let's look at the view counts.
Now, number one is definitely
the most common digit at the
start of the view counts,
followed by number two.
That's as it should be.
But it goes a bit wrong there
at the end, doesn't it?
Let's try the number
of comments on
each Numberphile video.
Again, number four seems to come
up more than you would
have expected.
Number one is still the
top, but I don't know.
It's not quite Benford-esque,
is it?
So the Numberphile statistics
don't seem to quite be
following the way we hoped.
Maybe that's because it's not
a big enough sample size.
We've only done just over
100 Numberphile videos.
But for those of you who are
familiar with my other
channels, yes, I do have quite a
few other channels, so those
of you who are familiar with
those other channels might be
aware that I've made, well,
well over 1,000 videos on
YouTube now.
That's a bigger sample size.
So I sent the statistics for
all those videos to Daniel,
and he did the same thing.
Let's find out what
happened there.
So these are the steps
for all my channels.
And let's go through
them one by one.
First of all, the durations.
There we go.
Not Benford-esque, is it?
In fact, number one's
not even top.
Number three is the most
common first digit.
Now, we've had a bit of a talk
about this, and we've got a
few theories as to why the
durations aren't working.
But rather than putting them
here in the video, I thought
it might be more fun for you
to think about it, propose
what you think's going
on, and put them in
comments under the video.
There's also a blog where we've
gone into it, and again,
there will be links under the
video in the full description,
so have a look at that.
But enough about durations.
Let's look at the view counts,
and the number of comments.
Plotting the view counts on all
my videos, the most common
first digit is 1, followed
by 2, followed by 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And the curve?
Well, quite Benford-esque.
Not bad, eh?
And looking at the number of
comments, again, remember this
is the first digit
in these numbers.
Have a look at that.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Again, a lovely Benford
curve there.
So it looks like even the
YouTube viewing statistics and
the number of comments are
following a Benford curve.
Now as I said, more
information,
links under the video.
Thank you to Daniel for
helping me out.
Thank you for all the other
people who volunteered to help
me out when I put out
the plea for help.
And we'll have more
videos soon.
And leave a comment
under this one.
Let's see if we can get this
one outside the curve.